>> WELCOME BACK, EVERYBODY,
MY GUEST TONIGHT SPENT
FOUR YEARS AS SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE MAKING HER THE
HIGHEST RANKING FEMALE
POLITICIAN IN AMERICAN HISTORY,
SORRY QUEEN LATIFAH,
PLEASE WELCOME CONGRESSWOMAN
NANCY PELOSI!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THANKS
FOR BEING BACK.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE A
FORMIDABLE ADVERSARY TO BE
TALKING TO ACROSSED TABLE.
ALL RIGHT?
WE MEET AGAIN, MY OLD
NEMESIS.
>> HELLO MY FRIEND.
>> Stephen: HELLO.
WE'RE NOT SO DIFFERENT, YOU
AND I.
WE BOTH HAVE OUR AGENDAS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE LAST
ONE YOU TRIED TO PUSH ON MY
SHOW.
THE LAST TIME YOU WERE HERE
WE CAME TO A MEETING OF THE
MINDS, YOU HAD SOMETHING
CALLED THE DISCLOSE AGO
WHERE YOU WOULD TRY TO GET
POLITICIANS TO DISCLOSE ALL
THE DONATIONS TO THEIR-- TO
THEIR ASSOCIATIVE PACS OR
501 C 4s.
IN RETURN I SAID I WOULD
HELP YOU IF YOU WOULD GET
MORE PEOPLE MORE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO BE PART OF MY
BETTER KNOW A DISTRICT
SERIES.
I UPHELD MY END OF THE
BARGAIN, YOU UPHELD YOUR END
OF THE BARGAIN.
WE PROVED PEOPLE COULD DO
THINGS ACROSS THE AISLE.
>> THERE WE GO.
ACROSS THE AISLE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Stephen: WHAT ARE YOU
PUSHING TONIGHT?
WHAT NEFARIOUS--
(LAUGHTER)
>> Stephen: NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO
VALUE ARE YOU PUSHING?
ON THE NATION TONIGHT?
>> TONIGHT I'M PUSHING OUR
AGENDA OF THE MIDDLE CLASS JUMP
START. THE  HEART OF IT IS WHEN
WOMEN SUCCEED AMERICA SUCCEEDS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
OK NO OFFENSE, MADAM,
LISTEN, NO OFFENSE BUT THAT
IS IMPLYING THAT WOMEN ARE
THE MIDDLE CLASS.
WHAT ABOUT THE MEN IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
HAVEN'T YOU JUST
EMASCULATED THEM.
>> NO, WE'RE GETTING TO
THAT.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THE
BEST THING WE CAN DO TO GROW
OUR MIDDLE CLASS IS TO UNLEASH
THE POWER OF WOMEN.
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK.
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE.
GOING ON, INVEST IN
EDUCATION TO KEEP AMERICA
NUMBER ONE, AND THIRD KEEP
JOBS HERE IN THE U.S. WITH
GOOD TAX POLICY INSTEAD OF
SENDING THEM OVERSEAS
AND BUILD ROADS, BRIDGES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE BROADBAND IN
OUR COUNTRY SO THAT ALL
AMERICANS CAN PARTICIPATE IN
OUR PROSPERITY AND IN AN
ECONOMY THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE, NOT JUST THE
PRIVILEGED FEW.
>> OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
(APPLAUSE)
WE WILL GET TO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE ENGAGING IN CLASS
WARFARE IN JUST A MOMENT,
OKAY.
YOU JUST DID IT, YOU JUST FIRED
A SHOT ACROSS MY BOW BUT HOW
WILL YOU GET IT DONE THOUGH,
BECAUSE NOTHING GETS DONE IN
WASHINGTON.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> NOTHING GETS DONE IN
WASHINGTON.
HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY GET
THIS DONE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO USE.
DO YOU HAVE NAKED PHOTOS OF
JOHN BOEHNER DOING
SOMETHING?
HOW YOU COULD POSSIBLY
GET-- BECAUSE REPUBLICANS-- YOU
GOT THE MENTAL IMAGE.
>> NO, I --
>> AND IF YOU DO, IF YOU DO
IS THE TAN UNIFORM.
>>
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> NOPE, ALL RIGHT.
HOW YOU COULD POSSIBLY GET
IT DONE?
>> WIN THE ELECTION.
ALL WE NEED IS 17 VOTES TO
TAKE BACK THE HOUSE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OR-- .
>> Stephen: FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Stephen: THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE.
>> WELL, FOR THEM, FOR
ISSUES THAT HELP THEM MEET
THEIR NEEDS.
>> Stephen: BUT THAT WOULD
MAKE YOU SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE AGAIN, PROBABLY.
>> WELL, SOMEBODY, SOME
DEMOCRAT.
>> Stephen: SOME, SOME
DEMOCRAT WEARING A BLUE
LINEN SUIT, WHO CARES WHO IT
IS.
WHY WOULD YOU EVER WANT THAT
JOB AGAIN?
JOHN BOEHNER IS ON THE EDGE
OF A NERVOUS BREAKDOWN.
HE LOOKS LIKE HE'S GOING TO
BURST INTO TEARS, ISN'T THAT
A HARD JOB?
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLY HARD
JOB TO HOLD, ISN'T IT?
>> WELL, WHEN WE DID, WE
WERE ABLE TO PASS THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE WALL
STREET REFORM.
WE WERE ABLE TO SAVE
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF GREEN
ACRES IN AMERICA.
GOOD THINGS ABOUT JOBS,
ABOUT HEALTH CARE, ABOUT
EDUCATION, ABOUT WORKING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T LOVE BEING SPEAKER,
BUT I LIKED GETTING THE JOB
DONE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Stephen: CAN YOU STICK
AROUND FOR A MOMENT MORE
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO
PARTICULAR A LITTLE BREAK
BUT I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A COUPLE OF OTHER
THINGS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Stephen: WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH NANCY PELOSI.
PLEASE STICK AROUND.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> WELCOME BACK, EVERYBODY.
WE'RE HERE WITH
REPRESENTATIVE NANCY PELOSI.
NOW BEFORE THE BREAK, BY THE
WAY, IS IT SPEAKER PELOSI,
LEADER PELOSI, WHAT SHOULD I
CALL YOU.
>> NANCY.
>> OKAY.
I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL WHILE
I ATTACK YOU FOR ATTACKING
THE MIDDLE CLASS, OKAY.
>> NO, NO, I AM PROMOTING
THE MIDDLE CLASS.
>> OKAY, I FORGOT WHAT IS
THE NAME OF THE THING YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> MIDDLE CLASS JUMP-START.
>> WHEN WILL YOU START
JUMPING ON THE MIDDLE CLASS
>> WE'RE JUMPING FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO RAISE
TAXES.
GUYS LIKE ME MAKE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS A YEAR, ARE YOU
GOING TO RAISE TAXES ON ME.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
WHAT WE HAVE IS TO STOP
GIVING TAX BREAKS TO
CORPORATIONS THAT ARE
SHIPPING JOBS OVERSEAS,
INSTEAD OF GIVING TAX BREAKS TO
KEEP GOOD PAYING JOBS HERE.
>> Stephen: YOU KNOW I'M A
CORPORATION.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Stephen: THAT'S ATTACKING
ME.
I'M A CORPORATION AND THIS
ENTIRE SHOW IS WRITTEN IN
MALAYSIA --
>> AND WE'RE GOING TO BUILD
ROAD, BRIDGES, BROADBAND,
WATER SYSTEMS BY CLOSING TAX
LOOPHOLES FOR SPECIAL
INTERESTS IN THE TAX CODE.
>> Stephen: LET'S TALK ABOUT
A COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES
REAL QUICKLY.
IMMIGRATION, WHY DO YOU
THINK OBAMA IS ENCOURAGING
ALL THESE CHILDREN TO COME
TO THE UNITED STATES?
(LAUGHTER)
WHAT IS HIS PLAN?
WHAT IS HIS GRIFT HERE?
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO
REGISTER THESE 8-YEAR-OLDS
FROM GUATEMALA TO VOTE,
RIGHT?
>> I KNOW YOU'RE A VERY
DEVOUT CATHOLIC.
AND I WISH YOU WOULD READ
THE CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
BISHOP'S REPORT.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE BABY
JESUS BEING A REFUGE FROM
VIOLENCE AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND THEY TELL IT-- .
>> Stephen: HE DIDN'T ASK TO
BE A CITIZEN IN EGYPT.
HE DIDN'T ASK TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE FOR THE PHAROAH
HE WENT BACK TO THE HOLY
LAND EVENTUALLY.
>> THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR THE
PHAROAH IN THOSE DAYS.
>> Stephen: OKAY.
>> BUT THE FACT IS-- .
>> Stephen: I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT.
>> THAT WAS NOT A DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM.
NO-- THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS.
AND IT NEEDS A HUMANITARIAN
RESPONSE, AND IT ALSO NEEDS
A RESPONSE THAT SAYS IF YOU
HAVE A LEGITIMATE CLAIM FOR
REFUGEE STATUS OR ASYLUM,
THAT'S ONE THING.
IF NOT YOU'RE GOING BACK
HOME.
BUT LET'S DO THAT
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND LET'S DO
IT WITH RESPECT FOR THE
DIGNITY OF EACH OF THESE
PEOPLE.
SO-- .
>> Stephen: YOU LAUNCHED MIDDLE
CLASS JUMP-START,.
>> MIDDLE CLASS JUMP-START.
>> Stephen: LAST WEEK WHEN
WILL IT BE LAW.
>> NOW LET ME SAY THIS WHILE WE
WERE ANNOUNCING ON THE STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL WAVING THE
AMERICAN FLAG ABOUT THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND ALL THAT,
THE REPUBLICANS WERE INSIDE
WITH A HEARING TO SUE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR ENFORCING THE
LAW.
>> Stephen: WHY SHOULDN'T
YOU DO THAT?
THEY WANTED THE PRESIDENT TO
ROLL OUT THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT, YOU KNOW, SWIFTLY, AS
THEY ALWAYS HAVE WANTED.
(LAUGHTER)
>> NO WHAT THEY WANTED WAS
50 TIMES THEY VOTED TO
REPEAL THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT.
BUT THEY'RE TALKING PROCESS.
WE'RE TALKING PROGRESS,
WE'RE TALKING JOBS, THEY'RE
TALKING LAWSUITS.
>> Stephen: IF THE PRESIDENT
IS BEING A TYRANT WHAT
CHOICE DO THEY HAVE BUT TO
TAKE HIM TO COURT.
OBAMA CAN ALWAYS COUNTERSUE.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON CAN
GET MOBBED UP WITH LAWYERS
AND WE'LL LET JUDGE JUDY
DECIDE THE ENTIRE THING.
(LAUGHTER)
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING ME.
HOUSE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
NANCY PELOSI.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Stephen: WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK.